et parmi ces candidats de la france
insoumise dans les yvelines marc soriano
cet auteur dramaturge est installé en
résidence au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines depuis 2008
l'année au cours de laquelle il a décidé
de s'engager aux côtés de jean luc
mélenchon sa campagne est à l'image de
son activité théâtrale avec une oeuvre
artistique le jardin planétaire une
construction utilisés pour défendre
l'environnement il se présente dans la
2e circonscription celle notamment de
vélizy je vais axer ma campagne sur ces
questions là sur qu'est ce qu'on mange
qu'est-ce qu'on respire enfin tout ce
qui tout ce qui met en jeu le vivant et
qui nous concerne tous par delà les les
chicaillas habituels et les insoumis ce
sont ceux qui veulent relever la tête
contre le dogme libéral c'est à dire
celui des chiffres des tableaux de bord
de la rentabilité de la déshumanisation
permanente au profit de la rentabilité
de la compétitivité être insoumis c'est
tout simplement demandé à ce que l'homme
redevienne le centre des préoccupations
politiques et non pas l'argent qui comme
vous le savez ne se mange pas